What he's feeling has become known as Zoom fatigue.
...a type of mental strain that can come from any videoconferencing.
Judy Lee gets it too,..
...ever since the pandemic has kept her inside,...
...away from her usual in-person meetings.
I do feel like every time I got off of a Zoom call,...
...I had to go lie down.
Back-to-back meetings can be tiring, so what makes video chats worse?
When that webcam light turns on,...
...experts say the pressure to perform kicks in.
Plus, seeing yourself staring back at you only makes things worse.
It's really hard not to be self-conscious...
...and keep looking back up that corner of the screen...
...where you're seeing yourself.
The other thing is we're not used to...
...staring at people intently with eye contact.
That's why it can be so uncomfortable having so many colleagues...
...all staring back at you all at the same time,...
...each in their own little box...
in what some call Hollywood Squares mode.